hi there Steve here to talk about
languages and today I want to talk about
this all-important sense of achievement
we all know that when we feel we have
achieved something then you know I don't
know the physiology of it but I think
that a certain chemical you know
reactions or whatever changes take place
in the brain give us a positive feeling
about ourselves whenever we feel we have
done something achieved something it
encourages us and it encourages us to
continue doing it okay so it's very
important to have that sense of
achievement
unfortunately in language learning the
sense of achievement because the the
progression in our language skills is
such a gradual thing you know we don't
notice you know we did something and now
we have a sense of achievement if you go
to the gym and work out you come out
your muscles feel a little bit tighter
you've had a shower you feel good
whether you have dramatically improved
your physical fitness or not doesn't
matter you come out and you feel good
about yourself in language learning if
you spend an hour studying the language
reading or reviewing words or whatever
you're doing listening you don't have
that obvious feeling that wow look at
you know I like I feel better
so it's very important that we give
ourselves credit for what we have done
if say I say okay I'm gonna sit down for
an hour and I'm going to you know what
I'm doing right now with my Arabic as
I'm listening to my many stories on my
iPad and I'm reading along and there's
still words that I don't know and I
looked him up and I spend an hour I said
I was gonna spend an hour reviewing some
of these many stories that have listened
to in read before I did it for an hour
so I achieved it so it's very important
that I do that I say wow you know good I
feel good about it I said I was gonna
spend an hour with my Arabic I did it
now the benefits of that are long-term I
know that the more time and effort that
I and time in particular that I put into
whatever language it is
I am definitely improving my brain is
gradually getting more and more used to
the language so I should take from that
hour or half an hour a sense of
achievement if during the day I had
lessons on my you know smartphone and I
had five minutes here in ten minutes
there I like to give myself you know a
pat on the back for that but that's more
difficult to do the same with just
listening in the car because I'm also
driving I don't come away with that same
sense of achievement but when I sit down
I say okay I'm going to spend an hour
with the language when I do that then I
close the book or close the iPad or
whatever it might be and okay I got that
behind me I did that then I take away
from that a sense of achievement that's
also for example wide link we have so
many milestones you know words known
words read people follow their streaks
any of these measurements of their sort
of activity level because it's it's
important to realize that in language
it's the activity level that is the key
measure if you spend the time with the
language and I'm not talking about
reading grammar rules I'm talking about
actually allowing your brain to engage
with the language through the reading
listening talking writing that you are
improving you cannot but improve the
brain is getting more and more used to
the language so the activity is with
what matters so make sure that when you
spend some time with the language give
yourself credit for doing that so that
you have the sense of achievement
because a sense of achievement is very
important to our continued commitment to
to stay with the process now that's with
regard to achievement I also wanted to
mention someone asked if I could do a
video about the English word get so I
may just do that I may get to that you
know I get these questions and this but
the problem with that is you know you
can look up you can Google get and
you'll get ten different meanings you'll
get ten different meanings of the word
get get it
okay I get up in the morning but and you
can read it and you'll forget them and
you'll also see a whole bunch of column
phrasal verbs with get get up get in get
out whatever it might be but you'll
forget those two so what you have to do
is whenever you are reading listening
especially if you're on link you save
phrases you save phrases it's like in
Spanish you know I don't know a H or the
menos okay that's a phrasal verb you got
to learn that as a phrasal verb I don't
know whatever I feel felt ah you know
you can learn these phrasal verbs they
have different meanings than the
individual words that are components of
them you just have to get used to them
but anyway I just remembered that
someone asked me about that and I may
end up doing a video I'm get but I'm not
quite sure what I can say other than to
encourage people to try to notice all
the occurrences of the word get or any
other similar you know word in other
languages that has a variety of meanings
and combines with other words to you
know mean even different things so I
guess to bring it back to my original
subject if you can commit yourself to
spending the time reading listening
focusing sometimes underlining these
phrases as long as you look after that
end of it spending the time with the
language try to focus in on things that
you want to learn and then give yourself
or give yourselves a pat on the back for
having spent the time all these other
things will gradually fall into place
all right thank you for listening bye
for now
[Music]